Watch this.
Happy Pride. Okay, everybody. Everybody.
I want you to meet my brother Dave. Hi.
His husband Frank. Hi. And my soberina
Mia. My niece. Hi Mia. Elmo Cookie. Are
you ready to see my monster piece?
Ready? Jonathan Alan Monster is wearing
the latest in high monster fashions. Our
Jonathan Vanessover.
amilies.
Wow. What has happened to children's
entertainment? This is supposed to be
public education. Uh teaching you your
ABCs, but now it's teaching you your
gays. And it's okay to have multiple
dads and
non-binary, multiple genders. This is
crazy. Actually, Sesame Street, they
actually had a guy come on wearing a
dress tuxedo,
and every year it just gets worse and
worse and worse. We're going to push the
boundary a little more to where we have
literally a gay guy with a beard who's
wearing a skirt and devil horns. And
I've been saying this for years. I've
been saying gay pride and Satanism go
hand in hand. And I've actually had
people say, "No, that's a little bit too
far." But check this out. Go to any gay
parade, pride parade. Don't go
physically, but look it up on on the
internet, on the news or whatever. Will
you see Satanist there? Will you see
witches there and pagans there?
Absolutely. 100% of the time, yes. Now,
go to the pagan fest, the the Wiccan
fest. Will you see the pride flags? Will
you see the pride parades? Yes, 100%.
Um, when I did a show on Little Light
Studios about Disney's Owl House, it is
a cartoon where the the artist, the
creator of the show said she her pitch
to Disney was girl hangs out with witch
in hell. And Disney's like, "Yeah, let's
go for it." This was years ago.
And when I did the show and I did all
the breakdown about how she's literally
in hell, her aunt is a witch and all
this stuff, I didn't even know at the
time because it hadn't come out yet, but
she is a bisexual character. A cartoon
for children on Disney Channel. Why? How
come always the the witch who's in hell
has to be bisexual? Because it always
goes hand in hand. This is um this pride
flag that we see. It's it's not just um
oh we're representing
uh an alternative lifestyle and this is
you know representation for this type of
community. This is Satan's flag. This is
Lucifer's flag for the one world
religion, the one world order. And we
have churches that are flying this flag
now. I could pull up pictures and show
you. I've taken pictures myself of
Lutheran churches and Presbyterian
churches and they're flying that pride
flag. Think about the word pride in the
Bible. Where do you see the word pride?
Because pride was the first sin. Lucifer
fell from heaven literally because pride
came up in his heart. He saw his beauty
and he said, "I want to be higher than
God." And and that's pride. So pride is
not a good thing. Pride is a negative
thing. Um it's it's all about self and
it never was a good thing. This word
pride has never been a good thing. But
suddenly now we're we're pushing it out
like it's a good thing and pushing it to
the children and we're wrapping up all
kinds of things into this gay pride
flag. Let me let me show you this. Today
is Junth, an official governmentissued
holiday. And it's like, well, what is
Junth? June 19th, officially Junth,
National Independence Day, is a federal
holiday in the United States. It is
celebrated annually on June 19th to
commemorate the ending of slavery in the
United States. This is an amazing thing
to celebrate. I can get behind this. I'm
all about freedom. I'm all about
anti-slavery.
And so you have this day, but it's been
hijacked because when is the day? Right
in the middle of gay pride month. Okay,
so think about this. You have you have
freedom from slavery and I'm a
homosexual and I'm proud of it. These
are the two things that you have. We're
going to make holidays out of them.
Let's give I'm proud to be gay. Let's
give them a whole month. Gay pride
month, not a day. And right there in the
middle of that month, let's give one day
to celebrate freedom for
African-Americans to be free from
slavery.
And it's already engulfed by gay pride
month, right? The pride flag has been
adding more and more colors to it to
encompass all these different things.
This is actually an official post,
official X post from Sesame Street as
you can see right here. And it says R is
for rainbow.
I mean, they are really pushing this
thing. And it's talking about what do
the colors in the on the progress pride
flag mean? So now we're it's not just
pride now. It's actually progress. It's
progress. When
you take something that God has
designed, and something that creates
life, creates family, you completely
invert it into something that is an
abomination, causes
deadly diseases,
um, families to fall apart. It's the
opposite of procreation. It's actually
depopulation
because without straight people, you do
not have people in the world. So how is
this progress when you just think about
it rationally? Think about it logically.
Progress means growth, right? This is
the opposite of growth because this
lifestyle causes death, disease, and not
it's the opposite of families. These
things don't last and you cannot create
life. But it's saying progress pride
flag. What does it mean? Uh the six
rainbow stripes each have their own
meaning. Drawn from Gilbert Baker's
original 1978 design. So all these
colors represent these nature things.
Life, healing, sunlight, nature,
serenity, and spirit. Wonder what kind
of spirit that is. Right. I do believe
there is a spirit behind this movement.
And you can hear it in the S. the S and
the spirit, right? You hear it when
these people are involved in this
lifestyle. It's always the same spirit
that's speaking through them. I don't
understand why the lisp is always there,
but I I do believe that there's a
connection there. There's some kind of
serpent spirit going on there. But
notice they added these colors. The
brown and black stripes were added to
represent queer people of color and
those lost to the AIDS epidemic.
Why were they lost to AIDS?
Because when you take part in something
that God calls an abomination, when you
take his creation,
um, male genital and female genital,
they come together in a marriage and
they create life and a family and it's
supposed to be an exclusive family.
That's the way God designed it. But when
you take that method and you pervert it
and you twist it and you start putting
things where they don't belong in exiton
places, you're going to have
pandemics. You're going to have plagues.
You're going to have disease, death, and
sickness. So, how can we actually
justify this? If we know that a certain
lifestyle causes death and disease and
depopulation,
how could we actively get behind that
and say, "I support you. This is
progress. You do that." We We would But
we're in Bizarro world where we actually
consider ripping your child out of the
womb as a freedom, as a right.
But yet, if you took a a a dog, say I
had a dog, she got impregnated, she's
got four puppies in the womb. I only
want two of those puppies. I'm going to
hire a vet to use an ultrasound. They're
going to take an instrument, go in
there, and rip two of those puppies out
limb by limb.
I could probably go to jail for that. I
mean, this is like, it's insane. You
would have the world up in arms. I can't
believe you're sadistic. You're ripping
a puppy out of the womb. But a child, no
problem. Actually, we're going to fight
for that freedom. We're going to say
that that's a right. And we're going to
protest in the streets. Don't you dare
take away my freedoms. Don't you try to
put um rules and regulations on my
uterus, my body, my choice. Except it's
not your body, right? It's another body
inside of your body uh because of a
choice you made. and choices you make
have consequences and actions or uh
consequences. So, I'm wondering like how
this got wrapped up to where
this movement has this flag of pride
which is not is a negative uh trait and
they somehow got roped in. They they
bring in race and stuff because when gay
marriage got passed, when Obama was in,
if you disagreed with that, they called
you racist. Basically, they said to
disagree with gay marriage is equal to
being racist.
They're totally different. There's
nothing at all the same, but it's all
about manipulation, emotional
manipulation.
And
so, they have to wrap this up in there.
they have to wrap in the race card with
their movement so that they can get more
support. But, you know, if I were a
black person and I wanted to celebrate
Junth because it's all, you know, it's
about remembering when we got freedom
from slavery. I would be a little bit
upset that it got placed right in the
middle of
gay pride month while they're flying
flags and some for some reason now my
color is on that flag. I never asked to
be on that flag
but fortunately for me my color is not
on that flag and I think that's a little
bit um ex exclusive.
This is supposed to be about inclusion
and about acceptance and love and
tolerance and all these things, but for
me as a white heterosexual Christian
male, I feel really excluded. You know,
if there's a a pride pride month, it it
just says happy pride month. This is PBS
Kids, by the way. This is a one of their
little splash screens. I'm just I never
dreamed I'd see the day when public
television was like, "Yay, we're
celebrating being gay to kids." I mean,
this is PBS Kids. This isn't like Fox TV
or something. This is Pride Month. It
doesn't even say gay pride month. Happy
Pride Month. You're supposed to be able
to take pride in your sexuality, pride
in your lifestyle. And so I should be
able to just jump up in the parade and
say, "Hey, I'm a proud heterosexual
Christian and I'm proud white power, uh,
heterosexual power, and I love Christ. I
love being a Christian." So I guess the
misconception
is that all year round we get
representation.
But do you realize that Christianity is
like the most persecuted religion on
earth? If you're in a Muslim country and
you're a Christian, you can be killed.
If you're in North Korea and they find
out you're a Christian, you will be
killed in the streets. There are people
right now who are having Bible studies
by candle light in a basement because
some brave missionary went into their
country and gave them a Bible like
smuggled it in. And this person found
the the answers to life. They found the
word of God and and they'll die for it.
And they'll say, "I'll I'll be in this
Bible. I'll read this Bible every day
even though I know if I'm caught I will
be shot dead." and they go into a
basement and they have Bible studies by
candle light and they're doing it with
their life at risk. And yet in America,
every household has a Bible. Most phones
have a Bible app on there and we're not
even reading them. This is where Satan's
gotten us today to where every household
will have a Bible and they won't read
it. It It's so It's so sad, but it's
crazy to see that that's how cunning and
crafty Satan is. So, here's another
official Sesame Street. This Pride
Month, let's celebrate diversity and
unity. Spread love and acceptance.
Together, we can make a the world a
kinder place for all. Why are we
teaching children about being gay? I
mean, we're supposed to be talking about
what's healthy to eat, your alphabet,
your numbers. Where does this play into
a child's life? Just be realistic. Where
does this like we need to um have a
whole celebration, a whole month of
celebrating being gay? What's being gay?
Well, it's when a man is in love with a
man or a woman's in love with a woman
and and the kids just like, well, I
never heard of that before because a
child,
they're innocent. They're It's It's
interesting. It's uh the Bible says from
the mouth of babes. You know, it's like
truth always come out from the mouth of
babes. I saw a video, this was so
awesome. I saw a video where a girl was
in the back seat and the mom was going
through a drive-thru at McDonald's, I
think, maybe at Starbucks or something,
and she's ordering a a coffee and the
little girl in the back seat goes, "Can
I get a cookie, mom?" And the mom's
like, "No, no, we we got cookies at
home." And she goes, "Well, we got
coffee at home." Burn.
The mom was so put in her place. She's
like, "Can I get some cookies?"
So, I'm saying that because kids, they
don't have a filter. they they see the
world the way it really is. Sometimes
even even better than uh adults. We've
been so indoctrinated. We go through the
school systems and we're like, "Yes, we
are smart. We're intelligent because I
learned from the best of the best, the
schools." And really, we've just been we
went to indoctrination camps. That's all
we did to where now even in the the
schools they're teaching that they have
uh in kindergarten they're teaching
children about non-binary and and all
these things and different positions,
sexual positions and how to please
yourself and all this stuff that should
never be talked about to children. How
in the world do we get to a place where
we're tolerating that this is being
taught to children? It's mind-blowing.
Um, everyone's welcome on our street,
you know, and and that's the thing, like
I'm all about treating people with
kindness. This has nothing to do with
like bullying people or mistreating
people or not treating people with
kindness. I treat everybody equal. I
don't care if you're a man wearing a
dress. I'm going to come up to you and
say, "Hey, good good to see you." You
know, I'm going to treat people with
love, respect. I'm going to pray for
that person. I love that person. We all
have our own sins, our own vices, our
own addictions. I'm no better than
anyone else. I had my own addictions. I
I have my own struggles. We all have our
own things.
So why are we making this a celebration?
What if we had uh alcohol consumption
month, alcoholics pride month? I'm proud
to be an alcoholic. Don't you dare tell
me that this is a sin. This is my life.
I choose it. I was born this way. I
can't help it. I must drink alcohol
every day. I'm an addict and I'm proud
of it. It sounds utterly ridiculous.
It's um it's unhealthy. You literally
don't have love for that person because
you are telling them to be proud of this
thing that they're enslaved to, that
they're in bondage to. here. Sesame
Street creates family with two gay dads
during Pride Month. I mean, this is the
stuff that's coming out right now. Bert
and Ernie are indeed a gay couple. NBC
News says this in NPR News. Former
writer saw Bert and Ernie as a loving
couple. Sesame Street Workshop
disagrees. So, of course, like those who
have been in this for a long time are
gonna try to keep their name clean and
everything, but the guy who actually
worked on the set, the writer, okay, I
think the writer uh knows a little bit
something, right? And these two guys,
there there's always been a little bit
of uh sus suspect with these two. And
now it's starting to come out looking
back at Sesame Street's proud LGBTQ
history as a as it's rescued by Netflix.
So I just think this is crazy. Sesame
Street disputes writers claim that Bert
and Ernie are gay. Okay, so they might
be disputing it, but like I said, if the
writer says they're gay,
uh, that holds some weight. Interesting.
I mean, this is just crazy. This is all
Sesame Street official merchandise.
Happy Pride Month. Where you can get
on a pin. Maybe that's the year that
Sesame Street came out. If this is all
about pride, how come these faces are on
this pen? Are they telling you that
these characters are gay or are they
just like allies? You know, because I'm
seeing a rainbow here. I'm seeing
happy pride and I'm seeing faces of
people on here. Uh I would already
suspect
the count. He's a little bit flamboyant
anyway. And you know, Big Bird wears
eyeliner and has these big long
eyelashes and like pink rings on his
legs. Um but check this out. Listen to
this song.
[Music]
Elmo's got one daddy. I've got two. This
is a group of people at at Pridefest.
They are proud of their sexuality.
But that's what I'm saying. This is not
inclusive. This is exclusive because I
would not be accepted or welcomed in
there as a heterosexual Christian male.
It's just interesting. It's It's like
the whole concept shoots itself in the
foot. It it's like illogical all these
things that the that the left come out
with um like the free the nipple
movement. Free the nipple. I remember
this whole thing was these women were
saying that my chest should be able to
be bured just like a man's chest.
There's no different. A chest is a
chest. And so I was defending this as as
a father of a daughter who now is 14,
but at the time she was even younger
than that. And I was like, "So, you're
telling me that you agree with some
13-year-old topless 13-year-old bouncing
around on a playground with a bunch of
old guys watching?" And they were like,
"You're disgusting. How can you Why
would you even think of that? Why would
you even think of that?" Because you're
saying a chest is a chest. There's no
age limit on that. A a male chest from
birth to old man is is is acceptable to
be bared and shown. You're saying that
your chest is a chest as well. So when
does the age limit cut off? Like at
birth it's okay because there's not
developed and at 18 it's okay, fully
developed, but for some reason between
the ages of 10 and 11 and 12, 13. No,
this is what I'm talking about. It's
illogical. These people, they they they
think this is progress. It's just like
I'm talking about like my rights, my
womb. It's my right to rip a child out
of my womb. And that's progress to
destroy life, your own child.
Just like you cannot justify saying a
nipple is a nipple and a chest is a
chest because there's going to be some
disgusting, disturbing things in that
scenario. Because the the flip side of
that is you got a 9-year-old boy who
sees a grown topless woman. So now
you're exposing children to
female nudity, adult female nudity. Or
the flip of that is you have preubescent
pre-teen topless girls and old men
around and they they act like you know
it's the only reason that this has been
sexualized is because of our culture and
you know it's not though they're trying
to say you know in Africa women are
topless and they don't have they have a
lower rape and all that stuff which I
beg to differ. I highly doubt that
that's even true.
Look at this. All this all this
propaganda.
Why to the children? You want to promote
gay stuff all day long on adult
television? Go for it. I mean, adult
television is all trash anyways. Protect
the children. I don't care if you're
religious, Christian. We should all want
to protect innocent children from things
that are just not right. And I guess
that's where the the the problem is is
people see that this is right even
though it causes death and disease and
and destruction. So let's look at what
the Bible says about pride because this
is pride month. We are in the middle of
pride month. A whole month dedicated to
this word pride. Well, Proverbs 16:18
says pride goeth before destruction
and in hottie spirit before a fall. So
pride is actually a spirit, a hotty
spirit, someone that's full of
themselves, a narcissistic spirit. Why
are we taking something that's so toxic
and glorifying it and making a whole
month dedicated to it? I don't I don't
even know of any other months out there.
I do. We still have Black History Month.
Okay, that's cool. That's a whole month
dedicated to Black History. So, we have
Black History Month and we have gay
pride month. And then we got all these
other things that are really should be
celebrated for a longer period of time
like uh freedom from slavery and
appreciating your mother and father or
whatever. But those things get one day,
Martin Luther King Day,
um freedom from slavery day, but a whole
month dedicated to being proud. pride
over your sexuality. Mark 7:33 says it's
naming things that will not inherit the
kingdom of God. And it says thefts,
covetousness, wickedness, deceit,
lchivousness,
and evil eye, blasphemy, pride,
foolishness.
You know, any
reasonable, reasonable, rational,
logical person should agree with this
that pride is not something that is a
good trait. It's a toxic trait.
Narcissism, everybody wants to call
somebody a narcissist, but for some
reason when it comes to pride, we want
to celebrate this thing. I don't want to
live in a world where people are proud
and narcissistic
and arrogant. I want to live in a
perfect world where there's no thieves,
no wickedness, no deceit, no lies, no
pride. That's where I want to live. And
so, it's interesting when you see these
parades and they're wearing devil horns
or they're mocking Christ. They have,
you'll always see it at these pride
parades. You'll see Christ and he's
wearing a a rainbow robe or something or
somebody's pole dancing on Jesus who's
suffering on the cross. and you'll see
them strutting around wearing devil
horns and a pitchfork.
It's like it's so in your face. The
spiritual war, the the veil is gone.
It's no longer hidden anymore. It's
right in our faces. And still so much of
the world is blinded because the god of
this world, which is Satan, has blinded
the minds of of the people here that we
can't even see spiritual warfare for
what it is when it's right in front of
our faces. When you have
Pride being celebrated for a whole month
long and people are walking around
wearing devil horns and they're bringing
children into it to where grown men are
are encircling a young child and
throwing dollar bills at him while he
twerks. This is the type of disgusting
abominations that happen at these
festivals and we're supposed to support
that. I will not.
So here's a a list of things that that's
pride in the Bible. Proverbs 11:2 says,
"When pride cometh, then cometh shame,
but when the lowly but with the lowly is
wisdom." So the Bible flips everything
on its head. Worldly worldly knowledge
and uh worldly logic is flipped on its
head. The first shall be last, the head
shall be the tail, the tail shall be the
head, and the lowly are raised up. the
humble, the meek. The meek shall inherit
the earth, not the proud. So if one day
Christians are going to inherit the
earth for all eternity, guess who's
going to be here? The lowly and the
meek. Not the proud. Where are they
going to be? Ashes under the souls of
our feet. Not because God is intolerant
and hates people. He It says he's not
willing that any should perish, but that
all should come to repentance. He
doesn't want to see one person lost.
But when you choose, you make a
decision. I choose pride, homosexuality,
all these things. Abortion, murder, all
these things. You are choosing something
that makes you unfit for eternal life.
You are unfit. You're a discordant note
in a perfect paradise. You cannot be in
eternity. God wants you there and he's
saying, "Hey, I'm offering you eternal
life. If you'll accept my ways, I'm
going to create the world new and it's
going to be perfect. No lies, no theft,
no deceit, no pride. Do you want to be
there?" I say yes, 100%. I don't know
why anybody wouldn't want to be there,
but people are giving up eternity for
sexual perversion. And it's so sad. A
man's pride shall bring him low. See, if
you're proud, you will be brought low,
but honor shall uphold the humble in
spirit. Not a novice, lest being lifted
up with pride he fall into the
condemnation of the devil.
The wicked in his pride doth persecute
the poor. That's not nobody should be
backing that up. Nobody should be
supporting persecuting the poor. But
that's what pride does. That's what
arrogance does. That's what narcissism
does. I'm better than you. You are
worthless. You're poor. You're homeless.
Um, you need to be swept out of here,
shipped off somewhere. And so the pride
pride doth persecute the poor. Let them
be taken in the devices that they have
imagined. God says, "You want that?
I'll give you to I'll give you over to
those desires." God doesn't force
himself on anyone. He says, "I'll give
you what you want." And it breaks his
heart because he knows that this way
you're choosing leads to destruction.
But he's hoping that when he turns you
over to that, you'll reach rock bottom
and you'll say, "God, your ways are
better than mine. Save me. I need I need
help." And that's where that's where I
reached. I did it my way. And it was fun
for a while. And I But it reached rock
bottom. And I realized this is a
hopeless dead-end road. And I'm enslaved
to this bondage. I can't get out of this
myself. I need your help, Lord. And he
set me free overnight. And I haven't
been the same since. I've been I'm a new
creation in Christ. My mind has been
renewed. And I would never trade that
for anything in the world. Not all the
sexual perversion in the world. Not all
the money in the world. What profits a
man to gain the whole world and lose his
own soul. Eternal life. Nothing
compares.
God is is love. He wants to give you
eternal life, but he doesn't want to
immortalize wickedness.
Proverbs 14:3 says, "In the mouth of the
foolish is a rod of pride, but the lips
of the wise shall preserve them. He may
withdraw man from his purpose and hide
pride from man." In Daniel 5:20 it says,
"But when his heart was lifted up and
his mind hardened in pride, he was
deposed from his kingly throne and they
took his glory from him." Pride always
comes before the fall. Think about
Nebuchadnezzar, right? He threw
Shadrach, Meshach, and Abedneo in the
fiery furnace. They came out not even
smelling like smoke. And he said, "They
have the true God. everyone must worship
their god. And so he believed in the
true God. But then some time went by and
he's standing on the walls of Babylon
and he's like, "Is this not Babylon that
I have made?" Again, I I I my pride. And
he had to be humbled seven years as a
beast in the wilderness. Pride comes
before the fall for the sin of their
mouth and the words of their lips. Let
them even be taken in their pride. and
for cursing and lying which they speak.
Uh Ezekiel, behold, this was the
iniquity of thy sister Sodom. Again,
pride, fullness of bread, the abundance
of idleness was in her and in her
daughters. Neither did she strengthen
the hand of the poor and needy. So look,
this is this is God's character. He
says, you're proud. You're you're full
of bread. You're sitting there just
eating and being glutton
and abundance of idleness. You're
sitting around doing nothing.
And what does he want them to do? Why
don't you give to the poor? Why don't
you give to the needy? You cannot bash
God.
To reject God and say that he's um he's
a tyrannical dictator monster of a
person, that's a lie from the enemy. He
loves everyone. He wants He wants us to
not be idol, to not be a glutton, and
not be proud, and to give love to those
in need. Man, God is so good. Thou shalt
hide them in the secret
of thy presence, from the pride of man.
Thou shalt keep them secretly in a
pavilion, from the strife of tongues.
For all that is in the world, the lust
of the flesh and the lust of the eye,
the pride of life, is not of the father,
but of the world. So when you celebrate
a month dedicated to pride,
this is Satan's month. This is demon
month. Just like in the word pride
month, you see the word demon month.
It's right there in 1 John 2:16.
God doesn't want a world that is based
on pride. He wants a world that's based
on servant
serving others. When you when everyone
serves everyone, guess what? You never
have to be in you never have to worry.
You never have to be in want because
someone is going to serve you and you're
going to serve someone else. That's a
perfect world. Our the all of creation
was created that way. Rain gives to the
streams. Streams give to the rivers and
the rivers give to the lakes and the
lakes give to the oceans and the oceans
give to us and everything is a whole
giving system. Food is given to our
plants are given to us and we eat it and
we give back to the soil. We fertilize
the soil and it's this whole system of
giving. That's God's kingdom, not pride.
It's the total opposite
and for good reason. Now, this verse
right here, because you might be saying,
"Look, I don't I don't participate in
that. I'm not a homosexual." But I have
gay friends. I have gay family. And I'm
an ally. I stand with them. I I'm happy
that they have a month because, you
know, there's a lot of haters out there,
and they haven't been accepted for a
long time. And and now they get to come
out and be open and be themselves and be
accepted. And so, I I stand with them.
Look at what Romans 1:32 says. who
knowing the judgment of God, that they
which commit such things are worthy of
death. So those who are doing these
abominations are worthy of death. That's
what the Bible says. But it goes on and
says, "Not only do the same, but have
pleasure in them that do them."
If you are taking pleasure in
wickedness, if you go to the parades as
an ally, you are as guilty as if you are
participating in it because you are
promoting sin. You're being entertained
by sin. Same thing if you're watching
Harry Potter. I'm I don't do witchcraft.
I don't practice witchcraft. I just like
Harry Potter. I like watching
witchcraft. You're being entertained by
wickedness. I would never commit
adultery, but I I enjoy watching it on
screen. To look upon a woman, to lust
after her is the same as committing
adultery with you in your heart because
sin starts in the heart. God wants to
transform us, renew us. Not that we're
not so that we're just like white
knuckling. Okay, I can't do that. It's a
bunch of rules. I gotta check all the
boxes. I gotta fight fight not to not to
sin. It's about renewing you to where
you detest sin. The things that I used
to love disgust me when I see people
consuming alcohol and smoking marijuana,
which I used to love. I mean, you look
at my old pictures. I'm glamorizing
drinking and smoking. And I hate it now
because I know what it does. I know it
ruins lives. I know it ruins families. I
hate everything about it. That's only
because of God. That's not me. I was
born this way. I could use the same
excuse. I was born loving the feeling of
alcohol, loving the feeling of being
high on marijuana. I was born this way.
I can't help it. So, I should be proud
of that and I should you should accept
me and you know, no job can turn me down
because I'm an alcoholic. This is just
who I am. Um, but that's not the way it
is because we understand that these are
destructive lifestyles. But for some
reason, we want to put the blinders on
when it comes to this lifestyle that is
also every bit as destructive. Look up
the statistics.
Um, what percentage of people
have obtained have uh been, you know,
got AIDS? It's the homosexual community,
especially for some reason
African-American males more susceptible.
And so that's where that lifestyle
leads.
And so I wanted to look at the
definition of pride. This is just a a
definition. This is the Greek
or the Hebrew. Which is this? This is
I'm actually not. This is the Hebrew.
Exaltation,
arrogance,
lifting up pride. These are things that
no one should be standing for. Nobody
should be supporting this type thing.
But yet we have by law a whole month
dedicated to it. And here's in the Greek
and it says hottiness. Hottiness is not
a good thing. So you know I'm just
trying to share this because I want to
think logical. That's what I all this
whole channel is about
disconnecting from your emotions because
the heart is deceitfully wicked above
all things. Desperately wicked. who can
know it. We can't live life according to
our emotions and our feelings because
truth is black and white. Truth is in
the pages of the Bible. It's not
relative. It's definite. And so on this
channel, we say it's cool to use your
brain. That's why our logo is a a man
with a brain and he's wearing sunglasses
because it's cool to use your There's so
much propaganda out there that says it's
not cool to use your brain. actually
you're a geek and a nerd and you get
shoved in the locker if you think so.
Don't you want to be the dumb cool guy
that gets the chick, right? But that is
just propaganda because dumb people are
easier to control
by in the spirit world and in the by the
governments because Satan works through
the governments. So, of course, we're
going to legalize gay marriage and of
course we're going to have a whole month
dedicated to gay pride and of course
we're going to have abortion clinics so
that you can rip your baby out of the
womb. We want that because this is
Satan's world.
Thank you guys so much for being in
here. I hope this was a blessing to you.
If it was, please give it a thumbs up.
It really helps get this into the
algorithm. I hope this has caused
someone to think because we can use
logic, rationality, and we can just see
that pride, arrogance, narcissism is
nothing to be celebrated. We should
actually be humble and meek and serve
others and treat others kindly and you
know that's that's what this whole pride
thing is under the guise of acceptance
and love but it's really not. It's the
exact opposite of love. Pride and love
complete polar opposites. That's a
no-brainer. If you like this, please
click like. Share this with your family
and friends. If you want to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got Cash App, Vinmo,
Zel, PayPal. We also got t-shirts on
candidtruth.org.
You can get those in hoodies, t-shirts.
We got a lot of cool shirts there and we
get $5 a piece from those. And we cannot
do this without you. We love you. We
thank you. And we will see you next time
on Candid Truth.